And why should I,
as a well-trained migrant,
if I had a choice
welcome to Germany,
of all places!
Tina kruppaler cleans up with the fairy tale
of skilled labor immigration.
High taxes and charges
deters many skilled workers.
In addition,
Germany is not exactly an entrepreneur
and is land-friendly.
A lot of,
high Lebenshaltungskosten
and rising crime
is not exactly 1 skilled worker magnet.
The fact is,
there is a shortage of skilled workers,
but only through migration
this problem cannot be solved.
In addition,
there are around 2 commas in Germany
6 million unemployed
with 2 million unfilled positions.
So why not
invest in your own population for the time being,
encourage retraining or further training,
take care of the education system?
Because the results of the PISA study
have clearly shown,
that Germany was behind,
40 to 50,000 young people,
which every year without a school leaving certificate
leave the school.
Instead of millions
Invest in integration and language courses,
Use time and energy,
to make Germany attractive again
and make it livable for its own population.
Because that is also a sad reality,
more and more qualified specialists are emigrating.